il
[Musique]
alors bonjour à tous avant de parler des
instruments de musique du futur je
devrais faire un petit sondage parmi
vous est ce que pouvaient lever la main
ceux qui ont un instrument de musique à
la maison
[Musique]
ok donc c'est à peu près tout le monde
est maintenant ce que tu veux élever la
main ce qu'ils ont fait un morceau avec
dans les six derniers mois
d'accord donc un peu moins de man et
mais quand même un peu plus que le vix
est plutôt pas mal
alors pourquoi souvent les raisons qu'on
a box et j'ai pas le temps de pratiquer
alors sous-entendu pas le temps
d'apprendre le solfège
surtout si les instruments classiques ou
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est bien
souvent un cahier ou alors pas le temps
d'apprendre à se servir des logiciels ce
qui concerne les instruments virtuels et
à toute une génération de nouveaux
instruments qui sont en train de sortir
en ce moment alors cds des instruments
qui sont généralement connecter sur
smartphone ou sur la tablette
ils peuvent prendre plusieurs formes
alors vous connaissez les lunchs pas
d'un excès où ces débats de ces avancées
les percussions danses et des samples y
en a d'autres qui sortent mais les
formes de lutte ou les formes de
tambours des formats mini guitare ou
même déconnecté
voilà et tous ces instruments font tous
le même constat et ont pour vocation de
rendre la musique accessible immédiate
et d'épargné
vu qu en musiciens d'avoir des donc
phase d'apprentissage et si possible
avec un potentiel musical le plus grand
possible pour illustrer sa je vais vous
parler d'un de ces instruments du futur
qui est ici que s'appelle le dus à l'eau
alors certains l'appellent l'accordéon
de dark vador
voilà je vais je vais vous raconter son
histoire
et puis vous montre un petit peu aussi
comment ça marche moi j'ai toujours
voulu devenir musicien c'était mon rêve
à moi et puis après la vie fait que bon
on fait pas tout lorsqu'on veut alors
comme certains d'entre vous je vais je
faisais un peu de musique quand même
nous c'est un peu de guitare un peu de
trombone en amateur et j'occupais un
poste de prof de maths en banlieue voilà
est donc l'histoire de cet instrument
commence avec avec ça non closes et
c'est pas d'accorder aux amphets elle
sait qu on sait qu'une scène zaz un
instrument africain et est en fait c'est
typiquement le genre de truc qu'on offre
à quelqu'un qui aime bien la musique
quand on s'appelle collier offrir nous
pouvons maintenant faire ça noël est
donc la première chose que j'ai fait
c'est la corde et or moi je fais du tout
africain je ne sais pas du tout les gab
africaine qui avait dessus et du coup
j'ai mis un bon vieux deruy fassol de
sitôt et voilà et du coup ça donne ça je
participe à surveiller bien je vous
entends déjà me l'a rapproché des micros
comme ça
[Musique]
voilà on l'a vu comme ça à
d'exceptionnelles mais par contre ce qui
se passe c'est que des fois je me
plantais et je faisais plusieurs de
l'avant même temps et puis ça sonnait
bien voilà alors je vous expliquer la
raison si j'ai fini par comprendre après
c'est que si on distribue les notes
comme ça do ré mi fa sol la si do
alternativement à gauche et à droite du
coup on a eu notre lot de chaque côté et
en musique un croyez moi sur parole aux
musiques quand on prend une autre sur
deux ça fait un accord voilà et du coup
bah vu que ça sonnait bien et tout lui
tient mais je vais essayer avec les
mathématiques de voir si on peut pas
représenter un peu sa part des dessins
voilà et donc c'est là que lé l'idée de
faire ce qu'allait donc ce clavier en
fait les accords se présenter par les
dessins va envoyer salle à ceux qui
triangle pas ça c'est le dessin
d'accords majeurs au hockey et ça c'est
le dessin d'un corps millar et là ça y
est vous savez faire les accords au
dialogue parce que c'est comme ça
partout sur le clavier majeurs i love
voilà donc les accords si vous savez les
faire chez titres de la gamme donc la
gamme c'est des touches qui sont allumés
vous vous en doutez donc en orange c'est
lé dos et et comme je l'expliqué j'ai dû
aller où on a un accord dans la main
droite un accord dans ma main gauche et
jacques terme à gauche maintenant
où toute la premier buddha jouabilité
parce que donner ça
[Musique]
où
en fait j'ai joué juste sur les touches
qui sont allumés donc en fait on se
prend pas la tête on l'harmonie tout
sous les doigts mais bon ce qu'on veut
faire en musique c'est des notes et pas
que ça en fait c'est vraiment de la
musique comme le faire donc moi en tout
cas à l'époque ce que je voulais faire
c'était toutes les musiques
j'appartiens à cette cette fichue
génération qui veut absolument tout est
puissant effort pour apprendre le but
surcroît voyons qu'ils se reconnaissent
nous voilà donc en fait moi je voulais
jouer bas du hip hop de l'électro de la
tête du rock du jazz objectivement du
classique
moi je voulais tout faire l'objectif il
était assez clair c'est faire le monstre
en musique autour de stadiers qui fait
tout et qui s'apprend simplement sachant
que moins à l'époque je connaissais rien
du tout comme vous et j'étais prof de
maths en banlieue j'avais un peu de
temps libre mais un peu un peu parce que
c'est parce qu'on prend
quel régal enfin bref et voilà mais par
contre je connaissais strictement rien
j'ai même enceinte et je ne faisais pas
de santé j'avais jamais tapé une ligne
de code j'avais jamais soudée quoi que
ce soit mais par contre j'avais google
s'était c'est en 2007 et qui avait plein
de frères qui mettait en ligne tout leur
savoir faire qu'elle soit on sait tous
que là j'en ai pas mal profité je
perdais qui connaissent art widow ce
genre de trucs
voilà c'est des bons gros ceux des
composants électroniques les gens du fil
des plans léchés ballet liste de
composants mais juste inventé c'est un
peu comme des lego et tous et c'est
génial ou un peu les doigts
c'est bien et puis voilà donc je fais
mon chrono dans ma cuisine et au couteau
suisse
et puis je dépose un brevet puis je
commence à partir sur les routes et ça
je le montre un millier de musiciens et
moi j'ai pour l'élite en gros ils m'ont
dit vas-y sa défense c'est génial font
ce genre etc
moi je fais ok bon je trouve encore un
peu d'huile on continue à bien celles
tout donc voilà en 2011 avec un ami au
fond de la société hodiall haut et voilà
le résultat vous le voyez ici
aujourd'hui du vannes oc start up en 18
et aimer ça en ile-de-france et le
produit également réalisé en france
donc aujourd'hui goyer juge devenu
entrepreneur je suis toujours de
musiciens en tout cas je peux vous
montrer comment ça marchait si vous êtes
jours de garde
donc je vous redis de commencer par
d'arros dont klaus est simple c'est une
grosse caisse caisse claire et bien
petits chars des roquettes reçues
[Musique]
et l'udc c'est un gros fainéant j'ai
envie de faire ça pendant une heure donc
je dirais qu'il faut mais pas voilà donc
du coup j'ai mis en boucle et j'ai les
mains libres
donc je vais choisir un autre sens josy
arens c'est très simple moins de 6 ans
bouton là et puis chaque touche que vous
voyez là correspond un son il ya donc et
marc à l'écran qu'il passe bien des
commentateurs l'autriche y voit là et ça
c'est la touche de la percu donc là y'a
marqué pire tu es vu que scénario sans
mettre des petits cons gare du mans
gagne soit ici que ça va bien voilà donc
là si je suis bien j'ai enregistré deux
fils qui a enregistré deux pistes da
silva tient ce bouton la d'envoi les
deux pistes
ça c'est la batterie aurait commencé par
ça et ça c'est lé père cuq est en verre
s en lecture si je me range semer en
stop
comme je relâche pour le touriste la
gérance et la bataille est maintenant je
vous remets là
ok donc maintenant pour poursuivre je
propose qu'on fasse un peu de funk un
système aura donc pour ça va prendre une
grosse basse bien grave
et avec ça je vais faire trois notes
donc je commence par là tout change
parce que c'est la tonalité perçage
faire la touche d'après et puis c'est le
cas tu savais que ces trois notes on va
faire un truc à vous mais moi c'est ou
parle
yes donc ça c'est de la grosse funk donc
qui dit fan des guitares
là je vais prendre une guitare et pour
faire de la funk il faut deux accords
donc ça c'est ptet sein de l'accord de
fin que numéro un et ça c'est des saints
de la corde fuck numéro 2 ok moi je avec
ça
[Musique]
voilà donc vous avez compris l'idée on
joue pour bouc et après on joue avec ses
boucles tout simplement
mais voilà par rapport aux sont donc je
défie ya plein de sons qui sont
embarqués message parolier un smartphone
et internet et cote ce sera le maître
l'idée c'est qu'on peut mettre n'importe
qu'elle semble à l'intérieur donc là
j'ai sélectionné décembre que j'aime et
que j'ai fait moi merci
m
là ce que je vais vous montrer
c'est la première partie du projet c'est
l'outil la deuxième partie du projet
c'est la communauté de joueurs qui va
avec
donc comme vous vous en doutez ou sur
cet instrument tuer les sorties en 2014
il ya une communauté de joueurs qui
commencent à se constituer autour
alors il ya des garçons il ya des filles
ça va de 8 à 88 ans il ya un petit peu
tout le monde il est très bons joueurs
qui font des vidéos qui font des
tutoriels et des débutants qui qu'ils du
coup ces tutoriels en gros l'idée c'est
que les uns après les autres
donc je vous expliquer comment ça se
passe à huy morceau kids à le faire
quelque part il a enregistré là dedans
est d'accord arru respect je peux mettre
sur mon ordi et après je peux le mettre
dans les nuages et du coup n'importe qui
15 à l'opl télécharger le mettre dedans
et donc se retrouve avec ça avec les
groupes qui sont ici et cette ligne de
base on est d'accord qu'elle est
mythique mais chez nous que vous vouliez
savoir jouer cette langue de basse donc
là il ya deux solutions soit vous allez
apprendre le solfège observatoire des
vous dans deux ans ou alors juste ou
cliqué sur l'a10 vous faites ça et là et
à la ligne de base qui s'affiche sur le
clavier lui-même donc là ça va un peu
vite mais regardez ralentir le tempo
[Musique]
du coup pour apprendre à jouer cet hymne
base mais il suffit juste de mettre le
doigt là où ça s'allume voilà donc c'est
un instrument qui s'apprend
vitesse de la lumière
alors juste pour pour terminer
j'aimerais faire en titre marc sur
l'histoire de la musique en lien avec ce
que je vous raconte de peter c'est que
toutes les musiques qu'on écoute
aujourd'hui pour la plupart en tout cas
sont issus de son des musiques
émergentes à ce que j'appelle des
musiques émergentes
ce sont des musiques qui sont créées par
des gens qui n'étaient pas spécialiste
avant je donne un exemple le blues le
blues c'est pas des africains ou
désormais un concret cette musique là cd
et les noirs américains qui aux états
unis en partant de rien qu'ils savaient
pas jeu de guitare est par contre il
sait écouter la musique s'écoute et les
100 km autour d'eux une loupe les
guitares sont réjouis d'un polar façon
et ça a donné le blues
d'autres exemples le hip hop r'n'b hip
hop fougue est conscient que c'est une
musique qui est inventé par des gens qui
ne jouait pas d'instrument ils se sont
appropriés des platines et les ont
détournés ils ont utilisé des pc sont
fait leur propre musique
la techno aussi qu'on entend beaucoup en
ce moment c'est une musique d'amateurs
la base
voilà donc que je vais revenir en fait
c'est que autour de l'instrument du
halot mégalo autour des autres
instruments dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure et des communautés musiciens
souvent d'atr justement qu'ils sont en
train de se constituer et peut-être y en
a d'ailleurs parmi vous qui les ont déjà
savaient qu'ils ont déjà utilisé ou qui
vont se l'approprier et qui vont
sûrement contribué à écrire la musique
10e voilà merci pour votre écoute pour
terminer ce cycle de conférences
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour remercier
toute l'équipe de l'ieseg co organisé
cette super soirée et en attendant la
musique du futur
je vais juste vous jouez un petit
classique on était un peu plus fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
[Musique]
hélas
oh
son prix est là
à
ca
il a bien besoin
[Applaudissements]